it seems like half the comments think
this movie is an AIDS safety an origin
story from the Hellboy universe and the
other half think we're dealing with The
Creature from the Black Lagoon
throughout this video I'll be presenting
evidence for both of these theories so
stay to the end where I'll give you my
answer on what this film actually is
early on we've got some surreal imagery
of furniture floating in an underwater
room but there are some fish swimming by
outside that window as well my
prediction is that these shots are part
of a dream sequence because generally in
my experience desk blunt don't work
underwater they just end up
electrocuting the victim I mean forget I
said that
but even if Lance did work underwater
they'd probably have to be plugged in in
the corner of the frame here you see
what appears to be a tentacle something
we've seen plenty of in the Hellboy
movies
whereas Creature from the Black Lagoon
is much more grounded in reality side
note I love how they put their Fox
Searchlight logo underwater it reminds
me of the 30th Century Fox thing they
used in Futurama her waking up right
here supports my theory that the shots
in the beginning of the trailer are part
of a dream and she's also in the same
room as that underwater part so I'm
pretty sure the scene represents her
waking up into the harsh reality of the
real-world responsibilities also time
seems to be a major theme in this movie
you'll see over and over and over in
this trailer that the tracking of time
seems to be important this could be due
to the fact that fish people in fiction
tend to live much longer than humans
which is the weird consistency when you
think about it considering how short
lifespans tend to be for actual fish one
example of a fictional fish person with
an extended lifespan you guessed it Abe
Sapien from Hellboy the Hellboy movies
seem to take place in the year they were
released as suggested by a reference to
the recent advent of YouTube in the
second film they show up on YouTube
Abe is David to have been discovered
alive in 1865 that makes him at least
139 years old during the first Hellboy
movie so perhaps the constant references
to time in the trailer played into the
theme that the protagonist allows us
really has a limited time with this fish
person
whatever he may turn out to be in the
grand scheme of thing I've seen romantic
complications caused by difference in
the speed of aging and other stories
before so I wouldn't be surprised if
that was a big part of the shape of
water as well I guess only time will
tell
okay I'm not according to the Internet
the movie takes place in 1963 and has
some connections to the Cold War however
I think this part of the film must start
a bit earlier in 1962 and maybe the
movie carries over into 63 because this
date September 18 falls on a Wednesday
in 63 but a Tuesday in 62 I looked up
the date in 1962 and apparently some
nuclear testing was performed by the
USSR that day in an interview earlier
this year doug jones who by the way is
the same actor who played Abe Sapien in
del Toro's Hellboy film said the
following about his role in the shape of
water I'm being studied and tested in
the US government facility in 1963 so
the Russian cold war is on the race for
space is on so there's all that backdrop
and that undercurrent I'm being tested
for how they can use me for advantages
in military or space travel or my
technology can make this usable for
human so they're trying to keep me a
secret from the Russians so that leads
me to believe that the shape of water is
about the u.s. developing the
supernatural research program as a
reaction to tread outpace the USSR in
the Cold War whether or not that turns
out to be the bureau for paranormal
research and defense section 51 from the
Hellboy franchise remains to be seen
moving on this wallpaper reminds me a
lot of the carpet in room 237 in the
shining that's probably just a
coincidence or at most an homage but it
did get my attention and makes me look
closer at it and notice that it kind of
looks like fish scales it's shown again
at the end of the trailer and it really
starts to look fishy when you look at it
underwater there's something special
about these shoes that they keep showing
I'm not entirely sure what it is yet but
go ahead and leave your ideas in the
comments and if I do a follow-up video
I'll put your comments up on the screen
she cleans these shoes with an oddly
specific duck brush thing and overall
she seems obsessed with cleaning because
in addition to keeping her own things
clean she also does it for a living
webbed fingers that could support the
idea of either Hellboy or Black Lagoon
but again I'd have to lean more towards
Hellboy the hand looks more humanoid
than the hands of the creature which are
much wider and more claw way that's not
to say that if this was related to
creature of the Black Lagoon that
Deltora wouldn't have updated the design
a bit it has been over 60 years since
the movie came out and to be fair it's
also been 9 years since the last time
Abe Sapien showed up on screen so it's
possible we'd see a fresh look there as
well
in the shot a warning on the wall reads
no lone zone which I guess means that no
one should ever be in there unsupervised
kind of like she is right here also if
you don't know what these are
it's a security measure meant to
reinforce that no lone zone rule the
door only opens if both buttons are
pressed at the same time so you need two
people to do it if you're a Hellboy fan
you probably didn't miss this one eggs
Abe Sapien loves eggs so that's a huge
connection however you'll notice that
the eyes but wait a minute where have I
seen this before but anyway you'll
notice that the eyes are not quite the
same a but do keep in mind that he can
change the appearance of his eyes using
those contacts that he wears even though
you're not supposed to wear your
contacts underwater also the creatures
in that French I do change their
appearance with age is just like anyone
else this chain gives the impression
that the creature might be dangerous
which would be a tally for Black Lagoon
Abe Sapien is not much of a combatant he
only gets into one scrum during the
series which she runs away from The
Creature from the Black Lagoon is
concentration 'l has the power to rock
the boat and breaks out of a cage with
thick wooden bars also this guy's hand
is wrapped up so it's likely he was
attacked by said creature the obvious
rebuttal is that if this creature so
dangerous why is it going and falling in
love with Amelie I mean Eliza
well dug gem says that this creature is
the last of its kind that doesn't mean
that it was always that way so maybe
this isn't the same Creature from the
Black Lagoon but a descendent if the
descendant was brought up under
different conditions maybe it's less
hostile and let's not forget that in The
Creature from the Black Lagoon all of
the men who are caught off guard are
killed but K the one females a group
leaves herself vulnerable but the
creature just touches her legs and then
at the end spoiler alert for creature
the black lagoon which came out over 60
years ago kidnaps her but does not kill
her
maybe Lagoon creatures need love - back
to the trailer this scientist guy claims
that the creature is intelligent capable
of language and understanding emotions
both Abe and the creature are
intelligent a breeds for books a day and
is able to extract information from
people he meets the creature devises a
plan to trap the boat inside the lagoon
using a huge tree branch Abe
demonstrates the ability to use language
which the creature does not that doesn't
mean it's impossible it just doesn't
happen during the movie I would argue
that both are capable of understanding
emotion Abe falls in love during the
second movie which leads to a glorious
scene involving two supernatural
monsters singing a love song The
Creature from the Black Lagoon expresses
both anger and love anger when he
retaliates at them for shooting at him
and love as I mentioned earlier towards
Kay in the shape of water trailer he
lies a place in music for the fish man
she offers him up some jazz music maybe
that's not his thing they settle on
classical music or at least something in
the style of classical music the artists
of the track is actually a Medellin Peru
she was born in 1974 over a decade after
this movie is supposed to take place so
that doesn't really make sense it seemed
Guillermo del Toro is pulling a Baz
Luhrmann in this instance and using
music from the wrong era but the point
is that this track which features
instrumentals that you might hear in
classical music is what makes this
creature dance and Abe Sapien is also a
fan of such music if you're curious
about the song itself it's called la
Javanese and the lyrics translate
roughly as follows I admit I went
through hell didn't you my love before I
caught wind of you met you my love
whether it pleases you or not in the
dancing Javanese we loved each other for
the length of a song that last line
could tie back into the time thing I
mentioned earlier because he lives much
longer than her it may feel like their
love was short-lived to him we also know
Abe is a sucker for poetry and love
songs and that may be the origin of why
those things resonate with him next
thing
natives in the Amazon worship it well
the black lagoon is located in the
Amazon aybe on the other hand was found
in Washington but we don't know where he
was located before that or if the
Amazonian natives worshipped a different
member of his species back in the day
before he became the last remaining
member this seems to be the same room as
he Liza's apartment from the beginning
of the trailer over here we see a
drawing board later in the trailer when
we see this rendering we know that Eliza
is most likely the artist there's also a
self-portrait of her peeking around a
corner possibly foreshadowing the fact
that she'll be sneaking around later in
the movie like in this next shot of the
trailer calling it now I think this
scene is part of the dream - outside the
movie theater if you look behind the
staircase we can make out part of a word
being that it is a cinema it probably
says feature or featured but I was
thinking what if it says creature or
even creature feature that could explain
why the creature is the only one
interested in seeing this movie perhaps
there's a jealousy subplot were the
creature longs for someone of its own
kind by the way if you can figure out
what movie this is let me know in the
comments the bloody handprint here
doesn't look like a normal human hand so
I'm going to guess that this is also the
creature meaning he probably escaped and
got himself into some trouble
this guy is asleep so he won't be much
help as a witness of this crime based on
this license plate it looks like the
movie takes place in Maryland possibly
Massachusetts if you're wondering where
Hellboy is set it's in New Jersey and if
you aren't familiar with American
geography all of those locations are set
in the Northeast region not too far away
from one another while Black Lagoon was
set in the Amazon much of that crew was
American so it would make sense that
they might capture something and bring
it back with them I don't know who's
back this is but this container on the
side stuck out to me it's labeled a VX a
company that develops vaccines to combat
parasitic diseases definitely a strange
item to have lying around the bathroom
now I could be wrong about this one but
I think that the voice at the beginning
and the end of the trailer is Doug Jones
obviously that's significant because he
played Abe Sapien but that doesn't
confirmed the shape of water is a
Hellboy spin off because director
Guillermo del Toro likes to work with
the same actors over and
again just as many directors do as part
of their auteur part of their
directorial style the reason that it
would be significant if it was indeed
his voice is a he talks and B refers to
Eliza as the princess without voice and
if you've seen Hellboy 2 you know he's
kind of got a thing for princesses I'm
not saying that Eliza is literally a
princess but he likes calling girl
princess so that's more evidence that
these movies are connected so now you
have a good argument for this movie
being connected to either the Hellboy or
a creature of the Black Lagoon
franchises I think there's quite a bit
more support for the Abe Sapien idea but
I have seen an article online that
basically shoots down the possibility
saying that fans are trying too hard to
connect the dots much as many of my
comments are subsided out these trailer
analysis videos the article also brings
up that Deltora legally wouldn't be able
to make such a film due to the reboot of
the franchise already being in
development but how do we know that del
Toro isn't involved in the reboot how do
we know that this movie isn't a part of
it Creature from the Black Lagoon is
also being remade in 2019 but nobody's
arguing against the possibility of that
you have a fish person who likes eggs
and vintage music there's no proof that
this one has telepathic abilities but he
clearly has a connection with a girl who
was mute she can't speak when he looks
at me she does not know how I am
incomplete she's able to understand her
despite the fact that she can't talk in
2002 before any of the Hellboy stuff
came out del Toro was briefly attached
to a remake of Creature from the Black
Lagoon so I think that he's just a fan
of it he's inspired by it and that's why
we see these similarities there's also
an article recently where mr. del Toro
flat-out denies the existence of Hellboy
3 does this mean that shape of water
can't be a Hellboy spinoff not exactly
I'm going to spoil the end of M night
Shyamalan split right now so if you
haven't seen that doesn't skip ahead
like 20 seconds but I think what gdt is
doing here is creating doubt to create
surprise I remember shortly before split
came out Shyamalan responded to a tweet
asking about a sequel to unbreakable he
said that he had his script sitting on
his kitchen counter and created the
expectation that this might be something
that happens a few years down the road
then just a few months after that we got
split and it was a delightful surprise I
see the shape of water kind of playing
out the same way I don't think it'll be
heavy-handed with the Hellboy references
I think it'll be its own movie that
happens
work in this universe kind of like split
last year kind of like 10 Cloverfield
Lane so that's what I believe I'm going
to put my eggs in that basket pun
intended if you're looking forward to
this movie to let me know by liking this
video and if you love creepy movies
you're in the right place go ahead and
subscribe to Suzy's world for new hoards
every week yes this is my video for this
week I'm going to be going on vacation
for the rest of the weekend so you'll
see me again on Sunday the 30th at 2
p.m. Pacific for the first ever episode
of the dead stream if you haven't heard
I'll be joined by Lady White Rabbit and
mortis media for our first ever
streaming event you don't want to miss
it so ring that death Bell for
notifications and I will see you in the
dead stream assuming we both survive